joining me now as former 2024 GOP
Presidential candidate v ramaswami v um
it seems like everything is upside down
in Joe Biden's
America look I think that the battle
line right now Laura is we are in the
middle of a war in this country between
a majority of us in this nation who love
our country and our basic shared values
and a fringe minority who has the
Democratic party in a Chokehold who hate
the United States of America and
everything we stand for and I do call it
a war because they're weaponizing one
element of our system after another
justice system Financial system media to
advance their objectives and so I think
conservatives need to wake up and say
that you know what the left has been far
ahead for a long time on Frontiers that
conservatives haven't paid great care to
protect the justice system and the
financial system amongst them but I do
think that we're going to have to think
over the longer run not just the short
run of this next election if we're
actually going to reclaim one standard
of the rule of law in this country one
standard of maximizing value in
financial markets and the media while
we're at it well you have to get power
well you have to get power back you have
to win elections in order to make
changes so I I think this election is
absolutely critical to doing that um I
want your reaction V to what happened
today when a mother in Boston was asked
about the
consequences of what was the political
decision made to close a recreation
center which is used by a lot of you
know at risk kids and others to house
migrants
and where those kids would end up going
watch this probably to the streets to
the streets where most of them are
already at you know you know like when
we look for help it seems like the state
and the governor and them people they
push us
away they want to turn our children to
animals we want better for our community
but this right here it's going to be a
show I know a lot of Republicans think
well there's no point in trying to go
after some of these voting blocks of
people who have been traditionally
Democrats I completely disagree with
that I think
African-Americans many of them seem to
be looking around and saying wait a
second this is not what I bargain
for absolutely and in fact in my
campaign I did Buck the advice of my
Consultants to go to the south side of
Chicago to go to the inter city of
Philadelphia in Kensington and what I
saw Laura was widespread agreement on
what are America first principles forget
Republican versus Democrat but the idea
that we should use our own resources in
this country to protect our own border
when they're converting Southshore High
School in the south side of Chicago to
an encampment for migrants at $7,000 per
migrant per month that's offensive
regardless of whether you're republican
or democrat or black or white and so I
do see an opportunity to your point
about the importance of winning this
election not only can we win this
election I think we can win this in a
landslide of a historic margin like
Reagan did for the second term in 20 in
1984 I think Trump can for his second
term in 2024 to say that you know what
you're going to bring along a
multiethnic workingclass coalition man
woman black white Democrat and even
Republican Independence alike to say
that a nation has borders America First
means all Americans not just the ones
who agree with us on every other issue
and I think if we approach this that way
we're going to have I think a historic
Landslide this November that dare I say
it could unite this country but it's up
to us to step up and seize it not just
to hide from that as I think the
Republican party has been prone to do
for a long time we have to show up and I
think that's the first step and if we do
I think I'm not accepting the political
Narrative of the left as gospel and you
know a lot of times Republicans will
shrink the second they're attacked by
the left and PBS just did that
documentary
exposing uh what was really going on
with how the January 6th you know uh
production was was created in the in the
committee looking into January 6 watch
this the one thing that we knew was the
information that we have is
compelling the thing we needed to do was
tell that to the American people in a
compelling way so that's why we brought
in a former president of ABC news they
wanted they wanted a Storyteller and
while they were brilliant they were
brilliant lawyers storytelling for a
mass audience is not what they
do
they admit they brought in a quote
Storyteller yeah yeah it's straight out
of George Orwell's Playbook is is the
reality as George Orwell will be rolling
over in his grave to see them selecting
figures from the media they realize
that's actually more powerful even
though they're controlling levers of
power in DC the thing they were car they
cared most about Laura was the narrative
that they wanted to drive not just the
selective disclosure of The Facts of
what didn't or didn't happen that day
but the spin they put on it for the
public to cons assume but it's up to us
now Laura not just to point to that
problem and say hey it's a top down
issue I think part of the problem is we
as a people also have become sheep and I
think it's up to every American across
the board to look ourselves in the
mirror and say we're not going to
swallow what we are force-fed a nation
of sheep does breed a government of
wolves and so yes it is the job of
political leaders to fix that government
but I think it's also the job of
everybody who's watching this program
right now every citizen at home to look
themselves in the mirror and say how do
we not swallow what we're forc fed
either and it's going to take both of
those things to get this country
back yeah we saw it during Co and we're
seeing it now and VI great to see you as
always thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else